hello everyone welcome to a nana string
sponsored webinar that's part of the lab
roots
coronavirus virtual webinar event series
my name is elizabeth schneider i am a
program manager here at nanastring
today we have the pleasure of presenting
insights into the pathogenesis of coven
19 as revealed by spatial biology
our speakers today are joe bicham
he is currently the chief scientific
officer and senior vice president of r
d for nanostring technologies based here
in seattle washington
he'll give a quick introduction to nana
string technology
and then we have presenting the latter
half we have dr chris mason he's an
associate professor of genomics
physiology and biophysics
at will cornell medicine and as well
we have dr rob schwartz who is a
collaborator of
dr mason and he's an assistant professor
of medicine
in the department of physiology
biophysics and systems biology
biology also at weill cornell you can
pose
questions to the speaker during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your screen labeled ask a
question
and click on the send button and
questions will be addressed at the end
of the presentation
thank you so much our speakers and now
we will begin the webinar
thanks elizabeth and uh it's fun to be
here in front of a
whole crowd interested in understanding
the pathogenesis of covid19
i'm going to describe to you the
technology behind the work that chris
and rob did at will cornell
just to give you a little bit of an
introduction that's a picture of my lab
there you see in seattle washington
um manustring is a company of about 550
people i got 200 people in r d and they
did a lot of this work
to help develop this technology i'm
really going to talk about two types of
technologies that we developed
associated with the coven 19 crisis you
can see the genomics digital spatial
profiler is how we do spatial profiling
of the rapid autopsy issues that you'll
be hearing from from
rob and chris but we also have
and develop technologies around the
encounter analysis system which is a
non-spatially resolved system
these are technologies we develop for
profiling out of blood
so the technologies we developed are
highlighted here we're interested in
molecular response cellular response
tissue damage and individual
susceptibilities
and we're developing them for both bulk
assays and blood and also spatial assays
now that you know the cova 19 this is
all about
you got to work fast here this is not is
the crisis we had to put together a lot
of technologies in a hurry
and you know how fast you can actually
get feed the biological discovery is
going to be a theme of this presentation
for both
me and chris because we need information
and we basically need it now
uh when we started this uh when this
whole thing was breaking actually
we were actually the part of nanostring
was actually in wuhan china
and we really started in interacting
with that group i
immediately set the r d group in motion
and we actually started immediately
working on tools we could develop for
kova 19
and we developed new gene expression
panels that were what we call spike in
panels and i'll show you
what some of that data looks like i
assembled a team of over 50 scientists
at manistering and we
decided we we began an entire focused
research effort our labs never closed
down
and i'll tell you about some new
technologies we developed and you
actually see them here
one of the other things we did is that
as we were doing this we started to get
contacted by
rapid autopsy programs around the world
and in these rapid autopsy programs they
really had to do discovery biology
on fixed tissue and if you're trying to
do discovery
biology on fixed tissue the high plex
technologies of the geomic system is
pretty much the only system in the world
that can accomplish this and uh you'll
hear from rob and chris because they
were one of the
uh the lucky first 10 we basically had
to close it out
i got four microscopes running 24 7 on
on coven 19 samples you can see there at
the bottom of may 20th i had to close
out
we can't take any more you can actually
still interact with us with some
specialized samples and
reach out to some of the answering
people to find out how to do that
we have to go pretty fast but uh these
are the kinds of
the the kinds of multiplexed assays that
we're bringing
up associated with coping 19 host
susceptibility
interferon responses innate immune cell
activation
tissue and lung function and impairment
the adaptive immune response and then
return
eventually to homeostasis if you're one
of the lucky ones to come out of the
other side
of this terrible disease okay
and as we put these technologies
together you can actually see they
expand greater than coban 19
and we're interested in a lot of these
other associated areas
our focus today is going to be totally
uncovered 19.
let me tell you about what we developed
for the bulk profiling in blood
and one of the key things when we're
developing this technology if you're
not super familiar with how an airstream
works we have an all digital
man method to measure up to 800 targets
at a time
and these targets and these typically
are gene expression targets i think all
the data i'm going to be showing you
today
would be gene expression target some
protein targeting
but the key thing is that we can
simultaneously monitor host
and pathogen together in a very facile
way
for best in class and working with the
tissue that is really the only kinds of
tissue
safe tissue you can work with in cobia
19 and these are fixed
paraffin embedded samples for uh for the
spatially resolved work
and fixed tail cells and tissue six
blood samples also from blood nasal
swabs and more
i think one of the key aspects of the
technology that
we've developed is that really one of
the key things is
you need your results and you need them
in a hurry so basically in one and a
half or two days
you measure 800 targets you've got the
biological information you want to
capture
it works on fish tissue and then you can
spend all your time
under trying to understand the biology
of this of cobin 19
and you're not worried about all that
how to set up your assay how to do the
measurements
and that's one of the key features of
our uh the way
nanostring technology works this is the
range of sample types you can see on the
right
and the types of pathogens you can
measure
on the left this
gives you an idea how important speed
was here
okay so this was actually one of the
very first gene expression
uh works that showed up in the
literature at all on coven 19.
these were whole blood profiling using
some of that technology that we rapidly
developed
in response to what was happening in
wulon
and you can see that we actually went
from this sort of an interesting example
this group this is actually the
singapore duke group actually uh the
actual work was carried out in singapore
they went from recruiting patients to a
publication
in 10 weeks okay that means you have to
have your technology
it's got to work out of the gate give
you high quality biological information
they were able to do that
it came out in cell journal in the host
microbe
literally 10 weeks after bringing in the
first patient
this gives you an idea on what some of
the things that we're measuring these
are blood profiling
and if you just look at those heat maps
there and these are covet 19 fatalities
there and you can see
three case studies on the upper right
graph there
and you can probably just use your eyes
i don't have a pointer here so you have
to bear with me
you can look at case one case two and
case three
and you see among the 770 genes that
we're measuring the digital expression
on
you can see the cup different color
patterns associated with the genes
associated with the response
of those three different cases and one
of the first types of biology that came
popping out of this
particular study was the involvement of
il1
pathways and some of the early you can
see the arrows there
some of the key markers on il1 pathways
that are associated with
the severity of the cases of the
fatalities that were being measured at
the singapore duke hospital there
um and and
that was what was published on i'm
leaving the absolute results here
hopefully eventually we'll be able to
get you pdfs of parts of this
of this study but gives you an idea of
the biological information that we are
able to rapidly recover
with 10 weeks from patient and to this
kind of information out
and we were able to publish on it
now shortly after that study a larger
case study showed up
in med archives i'm just going to
highlight that
again they saw interferon type 1
responses
in this particular case they were able
to use our technology to profile
50 different patients in their case
studies
and when you see that now i can show you
the heat maps of the responses
you can see these are much more detailed
because we've got many more
cases and you can see the no disease
heat map gene expression case
the mild to moderate coping 19 severe
and critical
cases and you can see that each one of
them has a unique gene expression
profile
that we are able to examine in the blood
uh
samples from these copin 19 patients
again i'm not going to go through all
the biology that's happening here
other than you can see there on section
b of that graph
that's the classic volcano plot where
you're trying to find
biomarkers associated with these
different
key phases of the disease and
criticalities
of the disease and down at the bottom
underneath the sea
are the key uh over-expressed change
gene expression pattern
pathways associated with gene with this
disease
progression so he went from a three case
study
to a 50 case study in med archive and
then almost immediately after that
actually may 21 of this year
published in new england journal of
medicine was some of the manistring
technologies embedded into a case study
that had enough information
to make it all all the way into new
england journal of medicine
i'm just going to highlight what some of
the gene expression patterns
uh associated with that uh that
particular
write-up of that scientific work you can
see a common theme here
you're actually doing coven 19s versus
various types of other
uh lung diseases in this case here
influenza a on one
on one hand and influenza and that
that's too small for me to see here
uh on another case and you're able to
see actually it was the same
influence a is the normals so-called
normals if you will
and then the two different sets of t
gene hits that you see
in the intersection of that venn diagram
are unique biomarkers associated with
cova-19
progression both from sort of
inflammatory pathway emphasis on one
side
and sort of sort of like the tissue
matrix elements on the right side if you
will
this sort of gives you a feeling of how
this technology we develop
the profile blood and
and it gives you an idea these are
actually how we put these kits together
you can take some of this cobia 19
information
and you can mix and match it with a lot
of different features of the gene
expression patterns
uh that gene expression panels that we
have inside nanostring so you have a
whole suite to choose from
these are some of the individual targets
that we that we measured and monitored
these are the mix and match panels that
you can use so you can take this
covet information if you're really
interested in the
inflammatory aspects of that you can see
that was in
one uh one of the presentations you
could actually take our
inflammation pathways and mix it up with
our our covet 19 panel plus
and that's how you sort of or you can
emphasize the innate immune response
the adaptive immune response and you can
do blood profiling and all these
dimensions
of the disease we're actually making a
770 plex totally devoted
to just this and this will be out
shortly
that sort of takes you through what i
want to describe on the non-spatially
resolved
uh technology and i'm going to bring you
now into
the technology we did we developed for
the spatial
examination of tobin 19 patient samples
as many of you know in this era of
technology development we've been
evolving from what was
used to be almost exclusive bulk
genomics types of profiling here
and then in 2012 a very fantastic
technology came along single cell rnac
came along and allowed us to get a lot
of additional information
you know the incredible thing is you do
all this single cell work
and in the end you really you need to
know how those sort
of those cells are organized in a
spatially resolved manner
because these single cells don't
actually do all the work it's actually
the tissues themselves
that do all the work and that was the
emphasis behind developing this
plex spatial biology technology called
geomics
now this is how geomics works and uh you
know uh
in some of my talks i actually have the
slide that actually shows the original
one napkin
where i scribbled out this idea this was
an idea i developed
back in january of 2016
and it was all trying to address how do
you get quantitative high plex
protein and quantitative hypoplex rna
information
from fixed tissue typical five micron
tissue slices ffp tissue slices
that represents biobank sample which is
really the currency of translational
research
the key trick behind how we did that was
instead of actually inserting all of our
assays into the tissue
and trying to deconvolve them with
colors or whatever i'm never going to do
ten thousand things at a time and
deconvolve it out of a microscope
so what we did is turn the entire thing
backwards you take your affinity
reagents you can see little antibodies
over there on the left side of the
screen
or your fish probes and actually instead
of putting colors associated with them
you put a sequencing bar code it's a 60
base pair piece of single stranded dna
and inside that barcode it says what
analyte you're connected to
so inside the sequence it tells me what
antibody i'm connected to
or inside that barcoding sequence that
tells me what mrna i'm connected to
now to make the thing spatially
resolvable we put that chemistry
together onto those affinity reagents
through a photo cleavable linker if you
think about what do microscopes do for a
living they shine light in small places
what this allowed us to do is literally
go onto an ffp tissue slice
you can see on the right-hand side of
the screen here and we can light it up
with four colors in a microscope that's
what microscopes do very well
but when i want to measure uh and let's
take chris's example that you're going
to hear about in a few minutes
if i want to take 2 000 mrnas and i want
to know what's happening exactly
in that tissue for 2000 mrnas i can
actually go there
i will have 2 000 invisible mrna fish
probes here
i go to that region of the tissue i
shine the uv light
all the little photo cleavable
sequencing barcodes would be released
from that tissue slice
and you literally drink them with a
micro capillary that sits right over the
tissue slice
and that generates what i call a digital
replica of the
of the affinity reagent as a function of
space
so i'll just bring you through this in a
big hurry here on the side
there's your slide you hit it with your
affinity reagents that all have these
invisible
photoclivable barcodes in there you have
a fluorescence
morphology markers we call these allow
you to see the tissue
and visualize that and you're going to
see that from chris
and rob's work we go to an interesting
pace we shine a uv light
the photo cleavable barcodes come off we
collect them put them in a micro tighter
plate that's on instrument
we can cycle through that tissue about
30 seconds collecting all these high
plex
multiplexed readouts and that allows us
to get this high flex in
discovery information from these
individual tissue slices
now i'm not going to have a lot of time
to describe to you the details of how
how uh this works but i will just a
little bit
uh this gives you an idea what a tissue
slice looks like inside the geomix dsp
and then when we profile the profiling
is by this uv light that we shined on
onto the tissue and the uv light that we
shine onto the tissue can take on very
complex patterns
because we built into the microscope two
semiconductor
chips each about the size of half of
your thumbnail with a million mirrors on
there
so when i want to do high plex profiling
of a unique
geometry inside the tissue in this
particular case say i wanted to monitor
every i want to do 2000 mrnas inside
just the tumor part of that tissue slice
that you see there that would mean all
those cells painted yellow
i could just those mirrors will ju adopt
a shape
that mimics that yellow stain on that
tissue slice identically
we expose it to uv light and we get a
pure signal out of only in this case the
tumor specific cells
but when we get to coven 19 we'll be
doing things where we'll be
looking at things surrounding the actual
uh
sars cov2 virus itself
and then we profile out of that you can
do rare cell profiling and i'm just uh
i'm going to glass gloss over that um
we've had very good success with this
technology we've now had about 16
publications show up back-to-back papers
and nature medicine was our very first
work on this
a couple of covers there clinical cancer
research cancer research
a couple back-to-backs in nature so this
is technology that's mature
it works you get high profile
publications like this
when you do these measurements
now i'm going to describe you how we
adapted this geomets to become a pure
discovery machine and the way we did
that is that
we actually the little photo cleveland
barcodes that you're looking at here on
the fish probes
now have been here's the photo cleavable
link or you can see it in that little
circle there
um and then off of the photo clearable
linker we put alumina sequencing indexes
that's where you can see the little
i5 and the i7 dual index probes for
aluminum sequencing
we got a universal molecular index in
there it allows you to dedupe all your
pcr library formation duplications
and then you got the unique geomics id
there and it's the id that tells you
what affinity reagent you're connected
to and what
what part of the rna that you're
examining
so in that kind of manner it allowed us
to generate infinite plaque
spatially resolved technologies you can
see over the last two years i've shown
here
we've gone from 84 genes that we do in
space
to now routinely in the lab i'm doing
almost
21 000 mrna probes in space
the work that chris and rob are going to
show you is right there in the middle
it's around 2 000 uh genes in space that
we'll be looking at then robin
chris will show you
now i'm going to sort of gloss over a
little bit but i think the key thing i'm
going to show you here
is that your raw illumina sequencing
rings are processed with a pipeline
that actually will link those illumina
sequencing rings back to the high
resolution
images of the tissue you're examining
that's one of the key aspects of
linking high plex njs sequencing with
the
actual spatial imaging and again i'm
showing you here these are the molecular
mechanisms we
engineered into our gene panels that we
examine the covenanting
samples with we work very closely with a
company called
acd it's part of a biotechnic company
and we develop visualization probes
around these unique
acd the visualization markers that allow
you to go in there
and see with your eyes where sarcos v2
is and then
actually do your profiling around that
and actually if you look at the
progression the virus tighter actually
it's up for a while and it goes down in
a big hurry
so you actually need more markers than
just sarco's v2
to do this kind of profiling that's why
we develop all these other
things with acd we also developed an
entire series
of fluorescent antibodies that will
allow you to quantitate unique aspects
inside the tissue
uh this gives you an idea of some of the
protein technologies that we're
embedding this gives you an idea sort of
a summary
of the rna probes that we'll be looking
at for visualization that you have
access to i'm now actually at the place
where i can show you what this all looks
like when you put it all
together so this gives you an idea on
here this is actually a rapid autopsy
uh fixed lung tissue here and on the
left side i
actually you're looking at the coven 19
virus probe over here
you can see the dark red and you can
this is a blow up of a piece of that
uh the ffp lung tissue and you can see
over here we've got the
acd probes now all working in
fluorescence mode and you can see how
they parallel this is a serial section
off of the bright field and now you can
see how we're lighting up exactly the
same spatial geometry that you can see
in the bright field
except with fluorescence work of course
you can have additional colors
so i'm actually lighting up temporis 2
and i'm actually
also lighting up here h2 receptors
and we simultaneously allow you to
visualize this
and then we can actually say okay look
at this interesting region where
uh sarco v2 is located let's probe what
the immune environment is around this
particular part of the tissue versus
that
and that's the work you're really going
to see from chris and rob
i can show you i can't show you a lot of
stuff because uh
even with rob and chris they're going to
have to be you know we're discovering
stuff nobody in the world knows
so we can't just actually be launching
it here on a webinar and uh
have everybody take off on all these
shits so i'll have to show you some of
the work we're doing here in this case
here
non-human primate work with uh rhesus
macaques
and these panels i'm talking to you
about work fine in a non-human
primate example this gives you an idea
of some of the
visualizations we're doing this is work
we do with harvard medical school
we're working hard on this and this is
actually a work in progress uh
but uh the harvard medical group allowed
us to actually show you what this looks
like
pre-publication this gives you an idea
of the
mrnas that we're now spatially locating
here
and you can look over on the left-hand
side the control region
and then you can look over here on the
right-hand side looking at regions that
are
virus high and virus low these are all
spatially resolved
multiple thousands of mrnas we're doing
in space
when you actually look and you look at
what are the differential expression
patterns now
between the covet 19 infected and then
the control
recess macaques we can actually start
generating volcano plots
which show the differential expression
in space of some of these key
regulators associated with the copen 19
progression
so if you look at that i can't tell you
a lot of these things but they were nice
enough
to allow you to allow us to tell you you
can see the up
regulated interferon response genes
there's mx1 if
three that we're able to find in here
cytokine pathways associated with stat1
and cxcl10 are all up regulated in these
particular tissue environments
and this is about oh i can actually show
you on those
biomarker hits at this time i'm looking
at my timer i'm actually right on time
for where i wanted to be
but hopefully i'm just sort of in
summary did this technology development
we did for both blood based
systems we got some great results this
is things you can
a two day turnaround time you get 800
answers
you can focus on what the biology of
these cobin 19 patients look like
at the patient level and you can see we
already got work that made it all the
way into the new england journal of
medicine so
you can really get high quality high
impact
manuscripts out in this area and then i
switched and showed you
all the technology we're developing for
the spatial examination of these coven
19 patients
and i took you all the way up to a
non-human primate study
now i'm going to have it handed off to
chris and rob and you're going to see
some absolutely exciting work
that the rapid autopsy program that will
cornell has done so i'm going to hand it
over to you
uh chris great thanks so much joe
um really a pleasure to be on the call
with you and also dr schwartz
uh with whom we have had the pleasure of
starting a really fun collaboration with
under uh very difficult times but we've
definitely been seeing a lot of new
biology
and i'm really excited to start to go
through it of what we've seen
so uh i won't belabor the point that the
outbreak we're all
uh in the middle of sort of a battling
is one of the worst in human history
and it's still on progressing and
ongoing and we really want to use some
of the newer technologies to
understand the basic uh you know basic
understanding of the virus its mutations
its changes
as well as its presentation and human
patients and also to look at it
environmentally look at it spatially
using some of the technologies
uh joe you just described with some of
the geo mix and some of the spatial
mapping uh sort of uh new technologies
that really give us a new window in
biology so
in particular i'll start actually i'll
just grab some of the work we're doing a
lot on rna-seq
as well as comparing to rt-pcr and doing
overall characterization
of some of the clinical samples we
basically started
banking and sequencing all the first
batches of patients that came through
the hospital
and described you a result of basically
the first 735 patients that came through
of which 2016 were positive the rest
were negative but i'll show you they did
have some other
uh sort of passengers and we also did
some environmental sampling and a good
number of controls as well for some of
these new samples
and so we're actually going to start to
compare some of the total rna seq
from some of these samples to the
spatial transcriptomic data
and really get a sense of what can we
look at the correlation between what's
in the np swab or the nasopharyngeal
swab
and what manifests in the different
tissues around the body
during the course of infection which as
you'll see uh towards the end from dr
schwartz
is also unfortunate about the autopsies
but from those
you know donated bodies we can actually
learn a lot about the tropism of the
virus and
and essentially what it's doing in the
body so again i'll go over the rna-seq
and i'll kick it off to dr schwartz to
describe some of the the digital spatial
transcriptomic profiling you can see
here
this was some coveted patients some flu
some non-viral
patient samples and then also normal
lung samples and
again using some of the latest panels
you just heard described
to really get an in-depth view of the
tissues but i'll start with
what did we see in general uh looking at
rna-seq and what can we expect
instead of the landscape of what the
infection is doing in human cells
and actually joe had a few slides in
some of the any jam and other papers
but we can see we did a total
transcriptomic profile of the patient
sample so this was
you know basically looking at all kinds
of rna and you can see here blue is
human rna
green is bacterial rna and you can see
in the rtpc are positive samples on the
right panel
the bursts of sarcov2 genome uh they're
an orange
in some cases we did get some false
negatives from rtpcr but other cases
uh you know for the most part it was
spot on and then
we saw other patient samples that almost
as much as 80
of the rna was viral rna after you ribo
deplete the sample so we could really
see
you know totality of the multi-kingdom
biology
which is one of the things actually uh i
think it was at lgbt a couple years ago
uh joe and i were talking about this
so i'm very excited to finally see it
deployed now on the platform because it
is
you know an entirely novel way to learn
about the biology to think you know
cross domain cross kingdom
and really uh look at all organisms that
might impact how our body responds and
i'll get back to that shortly
uh but you can see here we also can do a
deconvolution algorithm from the rna c
to look at which cell types are present
and also you can use of course with uh
some nanostring data but we can see
mostly affiliated in goblet cells and in
some
samples of subtle evidence of dendritic
cells but for the most part it was
ciliated in goblet cells or predominant
cell types in the samples we looked at
and there's another way to look at this
if you just separate them out with umap
plots you can actually see here
the density by rtpcr normalized viral
level
and also the predicted types of cells we
see both cell types seem to be getting
infected
at least at the site of uh collection
for the np swab and you can see that
across these
different variables as well here but the
other kind of cool thing about
sequencing it
is once you do the capturing actually
then you you know pull through and
sequence it
you then can align to this viral genome
and actually call genetic mutations and
trace
the evolutionary history of the virus so
we actually got from here these are high
quality assemblies and mappings
we can see some of the common variations
you see is kind of these vertical stripe
lines
and also as well as more rare mutations
from the viral sequence
and we've kind of overlaid this with
what's in gisa for some of the
larger global databases and actually one
of the most extraordinary things about
this time is that
any mutation we see we can immediately
reference and characterize
relative to the global database and then
understand it so for example
when we started to see mutations that
were even larger than snips for example
this was a nine base pair three amino
acid change uh that actually deleted a
part of the
conserved genome relative to sars from
2003 uh we could actually see you know
this is a conservative portion of the c
terminal region of n and sp1 which has
already been linked to
host chemokine dysregulation which is
exactly what we see
and we can take this data and then
characterize well do we see this and
other
samples across the world and indeed we
aren't the only ones we can see from
iceland from
places in ohio and england we can
actually quickly trace and see
where these other mutations appearing as
sort of a matter of course
and so that so that's you know not too
surprising for sequencing the virus but
i think what's also really inspiring to
think about what else you can learn
about the biology
when you have probes or you have
sequences coming from other viruses so
in particular
you know what's been done for the
seattle flu study for example and trevor
bedford has an amazing
twitter feed about this if you haven't
seen it is you know every year they've
been looking for
other viruses as they burst up in the in
the winter season
but now we can also do this with a total
transcriptome rna sequencing so
in this case we look to see for low
medium and high viral levels you can see
here in the middle or was it not
detected
or over on the right we looked to see
did we actually have evidence of
other viruses other respiratory
pathogens that might be present
and you can see over here we saw a
co-infection within thesaurus cov2
patients that were positive was
relatively rare
uh but we did see uh pneumonia we did
see other flavors
of flavors other influenzas other
rhinoviruses
other viruses present other rna viruses
uh that are present in these samples and
so you can see
uh you know in general once you're uh
star civv2 positive that's what's
driving a lot of the biology
uh but the interesting thing is when we
looked at the microbiome as well from
this total rna-seq data
we can actually see again the non-low
medium and high patients and these are
normal flora and airways or oral
microbiome are shared
and we can actually see that there is a
little bit of a disruption a microbial
disruption in these high viral tighter
patients
indicating either the patients were
susceptible before they went in or that
something
uh after infection had displaced and
actually disrupted the microbiome
density for these uh
generally commensals so that's another
interesting feature we've seen in the
data and we're starting to look more
in the geomets data sets and then also
echoing back what
joe had mentioned before is we do see
the human response in the rna
which we can see some of the exact same
genes you just saw in the previous
slides is some of the interferon
stimulated genes or
interferon related pathways you can see
really strongly upregulated
in particular actually if you look at
the pathways of these
the ones that really get upregulated are
the interferon response antiviral
modules
but also down here we can see disruption
of the olfactory signaling pathways
which we see more pronounced in some
patients that have lost sense of smell
or taste which is really
intriguing to think about what that
means clinically and also the hemoglobin
complex and also
looking at you know iron binding and
other oxygen binding pathways
that relate to some of the hemological
uh deficiencies and disruptions that
have been seen in patients as well
and maybe even linked to some of the
happy hypoxics that have been seen
clinically but although that's
speculation at this point
so the other thing we want to do is look
at basically cytokine and interferon
signaling and we can see here
il-6 and other cytokines and other
inflammatory interleukin markers
really disrupt especially in the high
viral tyre patients you can see and
we've also you know we this is
some figures from our paper that's uh
online but we've also
made a website where you can go and make
some of the same plots yourself which is
called
covajeans.wild.cornell.edu and it's a
place where
if you want to plot some of the data
from the study uh you can actually go
there and start to play with the data
and
built it basically as an online resource
for anyone in the field trying to learn
about you know when you see disruptive
expression
in your samples you want to learn about
the expression data you can go here to
play with it
and we're going to be actually now we've
got all these the spatial data will
start to
upload some of these data as well uh to
actually i think ab this is a nice
resource for the community
uh and the last few things about
clothesline is just we did observe also
getting back to some of the clotting and
and sort of blood
problems observing some of the patients
we could see complement factor pathways
are disrupted
also as a function of viral load and
then finally we tried to link to the
clinical metadata to see if we could
learn anything there and we did see for
example
in the high viral tighter patients a
high level of h2 expression that was uh
you know commensurate with the amount of
virus and we look to see clinically
you know did this uh change the risk of
infection which the answer is yes you
can see on the left here
not necessarily uh mortality but a
little bit of risk of intubation
but we did see the really the function
also of you know
hypertension is driving us a lot to some
degrees you're
driving a lot so with or without ace
inhibitors or angiotensin receptor
blockers arbs
uh both of them didn't fare well um you
know when they had hypertension so
we think you know the interestingly from
from the dead and the hospital records
it does have uh some risk of a higher
infection but not necessarily mortality
hypertension is actually what's driving
this
more than anything else we've seen and
so that's
um you know there's a lot of uh open
questions i think um
you know what what are the stages that
are present and uh
as a function of the virus uh during a
time of infection how does it move
through the body and and i think that's
what
uh dr schwartz will get you next to
think about what we can visualize
and i think um you know that's kind of
the i think i'll hand it over to dr
schwartz to start getting to some of
these questions
um well thank you very much for uh that
segue
uh dr mason and i just wanted again to
um thank the group here for the
opportunity to uh
be working on this project and how
excited uh this work has
has been and so with that said um you
know it has been mentioned by
um by joe and and chris there's a lot of
opening questions here with coping 19
which is really engendered kind of
a lot of the excitement here in its
study so
you know in the in kind of the
intersection here of
you know some of the types of problems
that we're seeing in our patients and
how we can address it with these
technologies
you know some of these questions are
like first are there different or
distinct stages of covid19 induced lung
injury or disease
um does stars cov2 virus induce lung
injury differ from other viral
infections such as flu
does sars cov2 induce lung injury differ
from other ards or acute respiratory
distress syndrome
or lung injury type of processes you
know what cell types are present in the
covid19 lungs
as compared to normal lung and injured
lung and is the spatial organization of
cells in the long altered in covid19
disease and so basically
to try to address this question we were
actually able to leverage
the spatial transcriptomics platform
using the geomets
and so basically the idea here was to
collect
a variety of lung tissues which chris
had already
mentioned earlier um from basically
patients who
had either died from covid19 related
acute respiratory distress syndrome or
ards
influenza influenza related ards
basically non-viral causes of ards
or just normal lung tissue and basically
we're doing this to try to understand
the similarities of differences
in host responses to a rds in each of
these settings
and also examining kind of what was
going on
within the tissue in a spatial context
so we basically examined at least to
start here
um at least three patients from each of
these different conditions
and these all were from ffpe samples
from these patients and that's also
important to note because one of the
challenges in studying covid19
is safety and so all these samples have
been processed in a way
which eliminates any active virus and so
these are all
safe for us to work with and so these
were profiled as already described by by
joe
so you know obviously we're here in new
york and
obviously these samples were all sent to
um to seattle
to nana string and um within the tissues
we actually
um picked
basically a variety of different regions
of interest so from the large airways
the vascular zones here the alveolar
zones and then also the macrophage
infiltrates which were denoted with that
cd68 staining
as described earlier by joe and so to
kind of give you an idea of what this
looks like
you can kind of get this here and so
this is normal tissue
basically and you can kind of see here
you know the large airways the vascular
and alveolar zones
and you can see that the tissue
structure is very nicely maintained
because this is
coming from more normal tissue and
essentially
each of these specific cell types were
labeled and we can identify each of the
regions of interest that were picked
within this so if we actually look at
covet tissue
there's first of all some damage that
obviously
that's occurred to the structure of this
tissue but each of these regions can
also be selected as seen
now basically the profiles sorry the
tissues were processed as already
described by joe through the processing
as
has delineated here and each region of
interest was essentially illuminated and
basically
put into the gmx pipeline and
so what you can see here sorry that went
a little too fast
basically there are a variety of areas
of interest that were processed
some of them were removed just during
quality control
just because they didn't have enough
cells or enough individual genes that
were
detected but you can see here that we do
obtain a lot of
areas of interest from the alveolar
zones and then a smaller group from
these large airways
and vascular zones and these were
crossing across all the different tissue
types here shown
on the right you know ards covid lungs
flu and and the normals
so basically obviously we don't
necessarily go into the specific
you know genes going across here but
what you can get an idea is that there's
a variety of genes that were pulled out
from this array including the spike in
genes from the specific kova genes
and even with some of the genes that
were moved from the
lower quality cut offs you still have we
had still had a lot of
genes that that were still able to be
assessed across all these different
samples
and so if we actually now start digging
more into the the data that we're seeing
here
is that one of the things that was
actually quite surprising to us
is that the normal lungs actually
clustered um
quite closely with each other but one
thing that we were surprised was that
you know we had ards from non-flu
and then ards from flu and we expected
these to actually be
you know it just it's ards but but
actually they cluster quite separately
within the analysis
and that's one thing that came out here
the other thing was is that
the the coveted lung was actually
clustered quite
uh also separately from each other
basically kind of capturing that even
though
um you know these are all patients who
ultimately died from covet
there's actually obviously quite
significant heterogeneity in the
different disease
components that we're capturing here
this
you know this is also reflected somewhat
in the differential gene expression
results that we're seeing
there is a you know heterogeneity among
the coveted lungs but
with that said um there's pretty
striking
um differences that are that are present
within the covered lungs as compared to
the flu lungs
covered lungs compared to the non-viral
lungs in covid
lungs compared to the normal lungs and i
know i'm not drilling down here deeply
into each of the specific genes that
we're seeing here
there's a lot of commonality that we
were seeing between between this and
across
all the different covid samples and this
is denoted here with the
essentially the signaling pathways that
are upregulated here
um you know you can see here you know
just on
on top here that the cytokine signaling
here is markedly upregulated which
is something that chris had already
pointed out earlier a variety of
interleukin signaling
tnf signaling and others and this is all
consistent with
what we're seeing here clinically and
as well as histologically in these
samples so it's really capturing that
quite well
and as you know as we drill more deeply
into this over time we're hoping to be
able to better understand
the biology here that is going on now
one of the technologies that that can be
deployed is just
quantitative single cell deconvolution
and it kind of gives us an idea of the
different cell types that are
present here um you can see here that
um with nebular zones you know we're
obviously capturing
a lot of the epithelial cells um and
some of the
immune cells as well as the blood cells
but as we
go through each of the different rois
that we examined we actually
are capturing the representative cell
types is exemplified here with the
ciliated cells
so um you know it really again gives us
an idea of some of the dynamics that are
going on here and that's really
exemplified here where you can see kind
of the differences
um between the different uh subtypes or
samples here with the ards
covid ards fluids and just in normal
tissues
and i mean basically we you know are
trying now you know this is kind of
early times but really is going to try
to use this data try to understand
the different cell infiltrates that are
being driven in the context of the
disease process
and how this may be uh ultimately uh
impacting
kind of on the histology that we're
seeing and also the
downstream signaling um now you
you know this is kind of looking at more
the bulk analysis but we can actually
look here
within the specific sections themselves
and see
where the different cell types are being
mapped spatially
within the sections themselves and you
know i think this is
one of the real strengths of this
platform here
you can see you know macrophages
monocytes neutrophils firewall
dc's and t cells and this is just the
different cell types that we're showing
you
here but you can actually see that in
the different
disease states that they're actually
quite different and if you actually just
drill down here
in the covid samples you know if you
look here on the left in the macrophages
or monocytes it's actually
if we link this now to the clinical
metadata which we just don't have enough
time to discuss
today um this actually correlates with
the
you know different stages of of the
disease
that's going on in the patients and so
this is
going to be really insightful as we link
this to the transcriptomic profiles
being generated
from each of these spatial sites
this is just sorry i forgot we had this
right here but this is just
zoomed in here for the macrophages uh
right here and
so i mean this data has just been very
exciting to correlate with what we've
been finding
uh clinically and with the clinical
metadata now you know
we can also cross this with the rna
scope technology
available with this and basically
looked at a variety of different markers
basically looking at the sars cov2 spike
ace ii and tempers ii
and you know this just kind of gives us
an idea of the different level of
expression of these different markers
here and i think this somewhat reflects
when you see some of the laws here just
the
overall global extent of damage and loss
of some of the cell types that
would be expressing this at these
different stages
but this is just giving you an idea of
what this looked like looks like
um you know in one of the patients what
basically large airways
had a lot of the tempers too but very
little that were present in the alveoli
and this was just a patient that had
very significant alveolar damage because
of the stage of illness that they had
you know covet 17 is in a later stage of
the illness
and we still then saw maintenance of
tempurs ii
throughout the tissue but a lot of loss
of the
um ace2 expression and that just
reflects of the cell types that were
being damaged or lost
in the course of the infection at this
stage in these patients
and you can see here you know not you
know it's not necessarily important
the specific patient information but
just
the differences that has how this is
reflected in the patient clinical
presentations
so i mean i think what we would be able
to conclude here and just as a summary
is that the clustering and differential
gene expression results show
that the samples are quite heterogeneous
genius
within the and ardius groups but
actually quite similar within the
normal flu groups which actually i mean
the normal made sense to us
but the flu groups we actually expect it
to be more heterogeneous genius but
actually turned out to be more
homogeneous and that might give us a
little more insight
into what's going on in the coveted
disease you know rna scope technology
can be leveraged to
specifically look at a variety of
different genes
specifically here looked for tempurs 2
and phase 2
and the quantitative single cell
deconvolution actually can be used to
show the specific cell types
that are in the covidien rd or groups
and they're actually more variable again
as as compared to the normal flu groups
so um i'll let uh basically uh
chris just uh um you know uh
basically show off his group here um who
have obviously contributed
to the group here and i'll just let
chris you you can hop on there
and do that and then i'll hop on hop
back up kit
great thing and awesome uh rob was
really great so it's been yeah then
we've both been really excited about the
data that's coming in so
just make the funding from um uh
everything from the nih to uh different
foundations such as world quantum
citadel who helped uh this house wells
gates foundation
uh thanks to collaborators especially
obviously dr schwartz here
uh and um you know everyone is also i've
got cornell and now streamers help get
this set up and then
uh pitch it back over to rob here for
her
and um you know i just really want to
also
just acknowledge my the funding agencies
which are the dod
the nih and some basically the
herschel trust and then also the people
have done this work in my lab
denuded here in red and former group
members who have also contributed to
this
but the most important is just also
their credit alan borczyk
and the the rapid autopsy group and
pathology group here at well cornell and
new york presbyterian
which really we've worked very hard
together to
to build this uh database and and
library of material and it's really been
due to their heroic efforts here
and so with that said i will turn it
back to the moderators here so
we can address some questions
thank you so much um joe and doctors
mason and schwartz we really
appreciate the presentation it was very
interesting
so as i mentioned in the beginning you
know feel free to
reach out with a question through the
chat we did receive some questions
throughout the presentation so i will go
ahead and address those now
please don't fret if we don't get to
your question in the q
a i believe the folks at labyrinths will
be collecting the questions
and hopefully we can follow up uh with
you specifically to address those
questions
after the virtual event is over
so the first question is is for joe from
nanastring
so you know why are encountering
genomics technologies um
especially well suited to study
infectious disease in covid19 and part
of the
question as well with asking you know um
what makes the encounter in geomix
technologies more
practical than say doing like um rna
sequencing
hey great thanks elizabeth and thanks
for the question
i think a lot of this comes down to uh
one is that and i think both rob and
chris uh
highlighted this is that you know these
are
dangerous materials so we really have to
be careful uh
and our hats off to the rapid autopsy
scientists down there doing that work
it is incredibly dangerous work so uh we
need to fix
these tissues and we need to fix these
blood samples so that
um you know we don't sending a
coronavirus through the mail up to
seattle and uh
and all my people getting uh what is
happening in new york and vice versa so
uh and now uh one thing to mention you
know i've been running r and d for
nashville for a number of years is that
we believe
six samples are so crucial for moving
forward translational science that
you know basically everything we do at
nanostring has to work on
fixed tissue um before or else we just
don't develop it
so both the encounter technology and the
genomics technologies are totally at
home
in fixed tissue and you know by
advancing this technology to the place
where we have essentially
infinite multiplexing now with the ngs
readouts you can now do pure discovery
on things that were normally never pure
discovery kinds of tissues so
i think that's the essence of it
elizabeth is uh we can work with the
right kind of tissue type
and then the one other key aspect is
that you want the scientists getting to
the biological information as fast as
possible you don't want to be waiting
for weeks for
something to come out of some pipeline
or some bioinformaticist that's gonna
that's gonna help you out you really
want to return the information to the
scientists so that they can really start
paying attention to the biology that's
what matters not the assay so you really
uh
and that's something we worked really
hard on too i think it's it's those two
factors elizabeth
great thanks joe another question that
came in also for you
is um you know is there the ability to
make custom
assays for gene expression on encounter
as well as
custom geomics protein and rna
assays yeah thanks elizabeth thanks for
the
question um it's absolutely essential i
think you know
a lot of companies like don't do custom
things and it's like
well you've got to do custom things
because there's going to be information
that chris knows and rob
knows that nobody in the world knows and
when you want to be able to probe
those types of things so yeah custom
reagents can be made for the encounter
as sort of our standard business so you
can
custom all the way up to 800 customs if
you want on the geomex
it's similar kind of thing you can have
custom probes come in just like we did a
custom collaboration with acd
to allow those visualization markers you
can pick your
special target of interest and custom
probes can be made for that
and you know they can be mixed in
directly with these panels
so that we reserve these barcode regions
just for
custom types of additions i think it's
really important
thanks elizabeth excellent
so we had a couple questions that came
in for the latter half of the
presentation
for dr mason and dr schwartz
so um how does the cellular composition
of these rapid autopsy samples differ
between the different disease states
like covid versus influenza and then you
know also just normal
lung tissue yeah
i guess i'll jump in uh this is chris
that you know we do see distinct
uh you know there is for sure some
overlap on the you know interferon
stimulated genes the response to the
infection some of the same pathways
but also there are unique ists there are
interference simulated genes that are
either distinct or even much more
strongly upregulated
in response to covid19 so it's
definitely not
you know quote just the flu as evidenced
by the molecular data
it really is much more disruptive and
also disruptive in distinct ways
uh especially in the you know in sort of
il-6 markers and also somebody
just general inflammation stress on the
body
i mean i i would just add to that
i mean basically you know one of the
things that we've been seeing is that
you know obviously the timing of the
infection
you know of where we're getting the
tissue matter so earlier on
the composition um you know appears to
be a more
you know neutrophilic type of
composition but as the
disease progresses over time we see a
much more macrophage infiltration and i
mean i think that's reflected in
what was seen on the geomex
analysis and you know i think what chris
just mentioned is what we're trying to
understand
is how is the signaling driving the
recruitment
of different cell types into the lung
and how that's contributing
to some of the downstream effects injury
and things that we're seeing
thank you so a few few more questions so
you guys had done some rna sequencing um
looking at
whole transcriptomics of some of these
um
covid 19 samples and then you did the
geomics in space
so what was the concordance if any
between the um
you know the rna sequencing data that
you did in bulk
and then the geomics data that you did
spatially
i guess i'll go first is the it's
actually been quite beautiful we see
some of the exact same signatures of the
genes they pick up at the site of
infection
really propagating through the other
sites of the body that either
have infected have infection or you know
or you know have it currently
and you can see this interesting you
know really it's a systemic disruption
of some of the same genes and pathways
and um
yeah it also just leads to also you know
you can see the immune system
coming in and getting uh you know really
trying to do what it can
with the disease but obviously in the
case of uh really advanced diseases
struggling to even uh keep up
but we actually don't have an r squared
to say we just got all this down on some
of these like yesterday so
we uh we'll be doing a lot of those
calculations now if we look across
different sites
across different cohorts what's the
correlation how predictive is one versus
the other but we're looking at that now
yeah i would echo that i mean from you
know we actually
from the autopsy samples which obviously
is looking at a slightly different
state which is you know you know at the
end point here
um but what we found is that it actually
correlates
quite closely with what uh the geomex
was showing
and um basically the one thing though
that obviously gmx is
is adding is kind of the spatial
information which we're losing
in the bulk analysis
great thank you so just a few more
questions
so um do you plan to do this profiling
and other types of tissue as well i mean
you mentioned earlier that you know
this virus um affects different tissues
in the body and could affect it
differently and
as a second part to that question do you
have any data on any of the
comorbidities
of these lung tissue samples from these
different patients
so we have all the clinical metadata
from all of these patients
you know the comorbidities that they
have age
gender medications they're on obviously
how long they've been in the hospital
and
you know so for so we we we have all
that data
and um basically
to answer the question do we plan on
running additional
tissues um you know that's something
that we're you know obviously
we first focused on the lung tissue
because obviously that's the
primary site that's leading to the death
and end point of these patients but
you know a lot of the other tissues that
we've been examining on autopsy have
been showing
very profound and unusual types of
injury that hasn't necessarily been
reported in other
disease states and so you know i think
there's definitely a lot of interest in
our side to
examine these tissues um with with
with the tech with these types of
technologies and approaches
excellent thank you so before we wrap up
i
myself as the moderator actually have a
question um
you know one of the things that we are
seeing with this particular virus as you
mentioned
is sort of the degree of havoc that it
reeks on
um you know different different tissues
and on you know the vasculature
you know the gut dns etc and some of the
initial data and joe highlighted this
in the first part of the presentation on
the encounter
side is suggesting that you know it's
not actually just the initial
infection and the virus that's doing the
most damage but it's really the
inflammatory response that is kind of
going into overdrive
and it's you know causing some of this
tissue damage and organ damage
those learnings could comment on that in
the context of this particular study
and some of the other things that you've
seen just in general of studying
you know stars kobe 2.
i mean i i think it's you know it's a
very important question
um you know basically you know what i
would say is is that
one of the things that we've been trying
to capture and understand is the
different stages
of the lung disease which i mean right
now we
you know one of the exciting things is
that everything we are learning is new
um but one of the issues has been
obviously we don't fully understand
the disease progression as it exists in
this context
you know my belief is that the um
that there's different stages of the
disease one where the virus is much more
active and and prevalent and then as you
mentioned kind of this
havoc stage which may or may not be
related at that point to active viral
replication and a high viral titer and
so
you know i think the way to address this
and what we're hoping to do is try to
partition between these different groups
by getting you know more samples more
data to try to better understand each of
these
these states and how they relate to each
other and how
the virus may be driving the latter
havoc outcome as you
as you put it
great thank you so much um so that wraps
up the q a portion of the webinar
again if you didn't get your questions
addressed
please go ahead and submit them through
the chat and we will be collecting them
at the end of the presentation
and we'll follow up with you thanks to
our speakers again
it was a very insightful presentation
and thank you all for watching
thanks thank you elizabeth good luck on
your research out there people thank you
guys